hello friends i am dr umar malik and
welcome to another video from math
simplified
in this video we will talk about
osteoarthritis
osteoarthritis also known as
degenerative joint disease
or degenerative arthritis is the most
common chronic joint condition
worldwide it occurs when the protective
cartilage that cushions the ends of your
bones
wears down over time although
osteoarthritis can damage
any joint the disorder most commonly
affects the joints in your hands
knees hips and spine this video on
osteoarthritis is a part of series of
videos on joint related issues
that we are trying to educate more
people about you can also check out
our other videos in this series like
diet for joint pain
rheumatic arthritis most common causes
of joint pain
etc so if you haven't watched our
previous
videos on this topic click the banner
above or the links in the description
box down below
to watch them after you've watched this
video so without further ado
let's begin with our video a joint is
where two bones come together
the ends of these bones are covered with
protective tissue
called cartilage cartilage is a tough
rubbery substance that's flexible and
softer than the bone
its job is to protect the ends of the
bone within a joint and to allow them to
move easily against
each other which leads to smooth
movement of the joints
and also helps the joints in bearing
your own body weight
with osteoarthritis this cartilage
breaks down
these bone surfaces become pitted and
rough
this can cause pain within the joint and
irritation in the surrounding tissues
damaged cartilage can't repair itself
this is because
cartilage doesn't contain any blood
vessels
when cartilage veers away completely the
cushioning buffer that it provides
decreases allowing for bone to bone
contact
this leads to pain stiffness and other
symptoms associated with osteoarthritis
osteoarthritis occurs most commonly in
older population
although it can occur in adults of any
age and is a leading cause of disability
and affects more than 30 million men
and women in the united states alone
let's begin by understanding how
osteoarthritis develops
well the most common cause of
osteoarthritis is
long-term joint damage and this is the
reason why osteoarthritis most commonly
occurs in
older population with age our joints get
damaged due to various reasons
this damage can accumulate over time the
older you are
the more wear and tear you have had on
your joints
direct joint damage may also lead to
osteoarthritis
this includes factors such as fractures
near the joints
joint dislocations torn cartilages
and ligament injuries other causes that
can lead to osteoarthritis
include joint malformations obesity
poor posture family history and in some
cases
gender females are usually at a higher
risk
due to menopausal changes
osteoarthritis can occur in any joint
however the most commonly affected areas
of the body
include the small joints of the hands
fingertips knees hips and spine
typically as a neck or lower back
the most common symptoms of
osteoarthritis include
pain in the joint which is usually the
presenting symptom
pain is especially more severe after
movements
and fatigue of the joint pain of
osteoarthritis is
also more common when the person wakes
up in the morning
you can feel certain discomfort when
pressing on the area of the joint
with your fingers which is known as
joint tenderness
joints can feel stiff especially in the
morning when you wake up
inflammation can also be present which
basically means your joints become
tender red and swollen as
osteoarthritis becomes more advanced
pain associated with it
becomes more intense over time
swelling in the joint and surrounding
area may also occur
recognizing the early symptoms of
osteoarthritis can help you to better
manage this condition
as the disease progresses in severity
other symptoms may also develop
such as increased swelling and
inflammation of the joint
normally synovial fluid acts as a
lubricant-like barrier
which helps to reduce friction during
movement in the joint
however in osteoarthritis it accumulates
in larger amounts and can cause
joint swelling fragments of broken off
cartilage may also float within the
synovial fluid
causing increased pain and swelling
you can also feel intense pain which
increases over time
you may feel pain during activities but
also when you are at rest you may feel
an increase in your pain level as the
day progresses or
more swelling in your joints if you have
used them a lot throughout the day
you can also experience decreased range
of motion of the joints involved
you may not be able to move the involved
joint easily
due to stiffness or pain in your joints
this can make it harder to do
day to day activities
as the joint continues to wear down
muscle weakness
bone spurs and joint deformity may also
develop
nerve involvement can also occur
especially if your spine is involved
there may be associated neural symptoms
such as weakness
numbness and tingling and shooting pain
depending upon the nerve root involved
the joint damage caused by severe
osteoarthritis
is irreversible but treatment can help
to reduce the symptoms
in one of our previous videos we
discussed about rheumatoid arthritis
although both osteoarthritis and
rheumatoid arthritis
affect the joint and present with pain
and swelling
these are entirely different diseases
osteoarthritis is a degenerative
condition
which basically means that it increases
in severity over time
rheumatide arthritis on the other hand
is an autoimmune disorder
people with rheumatoid arthritis have
immune system
that mistakenly damages the soft lining
around the joints
as the immune system damages the joints
fluid buildup within the joint occurs
causing stiffness pain swelling and
inflammation
to know more about rheumatic arthritis
watch our video by clicking the banner
above
if you're not sure which form of
arthritis you have your best
bet is to talk to your doctor your
doctor can easily diagnose the
appropriate condition
and help you to manage it in a better
way
osteoarthritis is often a slow
developing disease that can be hard to
diagnose
until it starts to cause pain or
debilitating symptoms
although your clinician can diagnose
osteoarthritis
by just examining your body and taking a
detailed history
he may use imaging and other tests to
confirm the diagnosis
in addition to x-rays your doctor may
use an mri scan to diagnose
osteoarthritis
this imaging test uses radio waves and a
magnetic field to create
images of bone and soft tissue
and has the highest diagnostic
capability other diagnostic tests
include a blood test to rule out other
conditions that can cause joint pain
such as rheumatoid arthritis or
infections
a joint fluid analysis can also be used
to determine
whether gout or infection is the
underlying cause of inflammation
osteoarthritis treatment is centered
upon
symptom management the type of treatment
that will help you the most will
largely be determined by the severity of
the symptoms
and their location often lifestyle
changes
over the counter medications and home
remedies will be enough to provide you
with relief from pain
stiffness and swelling at home
treatments and lifestyle changes for
osteoarthritis
include regular exercise weight
management
adequate sleep and heat and cold therapy
for the joints
physical activity strengthens the
muscles around your joints
and helps to relieve stiffness aim for
at least 20 to 30 minutes of physical
movement
at least every other day choose gentle
low impact activities such as walking or
swimming
stretching exercises in yoga can also
improve joint flexibility
and help with pain management
being overweight can put a strain on
your joints and can cause
pain shedding excess pounds helps to
relieve this pressure and reduces pain
a healthy weight can also lower your
risk of other health problems such as
diabetes and heart diseases
resting your muscles can reduce swelling
and inflammation
getting enough sleep at night can also
help you to manage
pain more effectively
you can experiment with heat or cold
therapy to relieve
muscle pain and stiffness apply a cold
or hot compress to sew joints for 15
to 20 minutes several times a day
gentle stretching exercises can be very
helpful for people with osteoarthritis
especially if you have stiffness or pain
in your knees
hips or back stretching can help improve
mobility and
range of motion in the joints as with
any exercise plan check with your doctor
before beginning to make sure it's the
right course of action for you
i will leave links to some of the videos
which specifically talk about
exercises for people with osteoarthritis
in the description box down below
so make sure to check them out
now let's look at the various
medications that are used to treat
osteoarthritis
there are a number of medications that
can help to provide relief from pain
and swelling that occurs in
osteoarthritis they include
oral pain killers like tylenol which
contains
acetaminophen topical painkillers are
also very commonly used
which are over the counter products and
are available as creams
gels and patches they help to numb the
joint area
and can provide pain relief especially
for mild arthritis
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
are most commonly used for managing the
pain
and swelling in osteoarthritis these
include drugs such as advil which
contains ibuprofen
a leaf containing naproxen and several
other drugs
antidepressant drugs in low doses are
also used in osteoarthritis
most commonly duloxetine is used which
increases the pain threshold of the
patient
steroids like prednisone are also used
in cases of severe osteoarthritis
this medication is available in oral
form
they may also be given by injecting
directly into the joint
your doctor may also recommend braces
and supports
in case of spine or severe knee
involvement
in some cases surgery such as knee
replacement or
hip replacement may also be required in
case of
very severe disease with this we come to
the end of this video
in our upcoming videos we'll be telling
you how to manage
osteoarthritis naturally if you want to
know the best diet for joint pain
watch our video on the topic by clicking
the banner above
we at med simplified are committed to
bringing you the latest and updated
content
you can support us by spreading the word
and sharing our videos to your friends
and family
also you can become a member of our
youtube channel or support us
on patreon all the links are in the
description below
thank you so much for watching and see
you in the next video